as I mentioned earlier another important
partner in this work has been the local
foundation community were delighted to
have several partners from these
organizations with us including our next
speaker grant Olaf on as all of you know
grants leadership within the Pittsburgh
philanthropic community dates back to
the early 90s he previously served as
Heinz endowments director of
communication later on as vice president
of program planning several years as
president and CEO of Pittsburgh
foundation before he came back to the
Heinz endowment in 2014 when he took the
helm as president of Heinz during my
tenure at Carnegie Mellon over the past
three four years I've come to know grant
as a thoughtful and concerned citizen a
champion of moral leadership who also
uses his position to drive creative
thinking about the issues that challenge
our world today we're deeply grateful to
the Heinz Foundation for their
contributions they've made to many
aspects of our community and and
university including Metro 21 what they
have done advances research development
of technologies for social good as well
as deployment here in Pittsburgh that
increasingly serve as a model for urban
innovation across the world please join
me in extending a warm welcome to Graham
[Applause]
I'd like to welcome you to the Teresa
Hinze classroom I'm actually just here
to make sure you don't trash the joint
you know Rick and Karen and Farnam and
Raj or a pretty wild bunch so okay so
you know I moved here twenty-seven years
ago and I've had the opportunity in that
time to see this city go from a place
that defined itself constantly in the
rearview mirror and talked about steel
to a place that's looking forward and
talks about technology and Carnegie
Mellon is at the center of and has been
at the center of that transformation I
remember when we talked about it in the
early 90s it sounded kind of hopeful and
silly in the same way that talking about
transforming the landscape around green
design and green building or reclaiming
or riverfronts or really turning our
downtown into a cultural Mecca seemed
silly at the time that those ideas were
born but Carnegie Mellon has helped make
the most fundamental transition of all
which is in the nature of our economy
come about and I feel smarter every time
I'm here when given a microphone I use
it and I really want to speak for a few
minutes to the folks in this room who
are going to be sticking what the work
through the day and sticking with the
work through the future because I think
that the message here around what you're
doing really needs to be stressed in a
couple of ways you know the partnership
that we have with CMU is one that we're
we're greatly honored to have we have
active grants to at least 10 CMU teams
and departments working on projects as
varied as visualizing air pollution love
that program mapping the spread of
artificial intelligence prototyping
affordable modular homes researching
early childhood brain development and
creating paths to stem for
african-american girls amazing range of
work that we're privileged to fund and
work with you on and the willingness of
faculty and staff here along with
students to co-develop projects like
these with us
and other members of the community is
one of this universities great strengths
and it's at the core I believe of what
makes metro 21 and this new initiative
so special I do need to pay tribute to
our philanthropic leader in this respect
who was Henry Hillman who had the vision
for traffic 21 which turned into Metro
21 and this is something that were
actually privileged to see in Pittsburg
a lot not just innovation by guys named
Henry like Henry Heinz and Henry Hillman
but but support for innovative ideas
from people who are leaders in the
community in a variety of platforms and
then willing to work together on things
that maybe we didn't help create but we
want to see advance one of the unique
aspects of Metro 21 has been its
intentional focus on breaking down
barriers between departments and
disciplines and fostering a holistic and
interdisciplinary approach to
identifying and solving problems I think
that's a big part of what I've known CMU
to be about it's a big part of your DNA
here the bridges you build between
departments and collaborations and
breakthroughs that come from that
collaboration between roboticists policy
and analysts business students engineers
and others has truly reframed some of
the issues that we're dealing with and
wit in ways that radically change how we
might address them how we even think of
solutions and that I think is the
promise of that I see in Metro 21 but as
excited as I am about the work that
you're doing there are three points that
I want to convey to you as you as you
start today's work and as we embark on
this on this new venture and the the
three thoughts or one one is really a
point of affirmation the second is a
profound caution and the third is a
challenge to everyone in this room and I
think it's a challenge that you probably
already have internalized but I'm gonna
give it to you anyway because I just
think it's so important for everyone
who's involved in this work we're
thinking about being involved in this
work to stay close to the first point
the point of affirmation is simply to
underscore the importance of an
institute like this and the video good
as it is doesn't quite get at it to the
extent that I think that the profundity
of what is at stake
to the extent that it could cities and
regions are increasingly the labs and
proving grounds of human society as
Bruce Katz from Brookings has pointed
out national and even state governments
are locked in dysfunction and paralysis
at a regional level in places like
Pittsburgh we still find the spirit and
resolve to address the challenges that
hinder us we know however that the
challenges facing cities whether it's
failing infrastructure like Carina
talked about multi-generational poverty
or planning for climate change can't be
boiled down to one technological or
policy solution it requires systems
thinking and systems approaches to bring
together the expertise of many toward
common goals
now commerce today which also gets
thought about a lot in these halls
increasingly thinks in terms of global
scale and too quickly dismisses local
community as a small scale commodity but
as we have seen play out endlessly in
recent years human society still
functions at a local scale we may buy
your product and download your app and
everyone in the world may be linked on
your social media platform but what we
care about at the end of the day is
what's happening around us here is where
we can still see past differences find
common ground build effective government
solve epic challenges and prove that
democracy still works so no small stakes
and if we really want to reinvent the
future in a positive way then we have to
prove we can do it here wherever here is
and I believe you've started to build
the platform to make that happen through
the smart cities Institute in Metro 21
but now and this is my second point
please allow me to often offer a caution
around this we all know that technology
is changing rapidly and that these
changes are having profound impacts on
our daily lives we also know that
Pittsburgh and CMU are at the epicenter
of many of the technologies that we will
reshape our economy and our built
environment in the coming decades
driverless vehicles will dramatically
shift our cities or constructed
automation and AI will change the face
of entire industries complex algorithms
will blah blah blah you know the story
but the key fact is that none of these
things happen
in a vacuum and they are not
value-neutral there are moral and
ethical choices that whether you are
intentional about them or not get baked
into the DNA of these technologies into
the ways in which they are deployed the
ethicist Nick Bostrom offered a
wonderful allegory for this he asked us
to imagine an artificial intelligence
designed to produce as many paper clips
as possible the paper clip Maximizer are
you all familiar with us eventually this
AI would come to the conclusion that the
humans who built it could get in the way
of its ability to produce paperclips we
use too much stuff that could be better
used to make paperclips we might turn
the Machine off or reprogram it we might
turn it and going even further we were
made up of atoms that could be better
into more productive use for paperclips
so you end up with the technology then
theory started with a totally innocuous
goal but eventually leads to a future
where there are no humans and a whole
bunch of paperclips if that sounds
ridiculous you aren't paying attention
and I know you are we saw a real-world
example of this cautionary tale just a
couple of weeks ago maybe we're going
through another one right now when the
stock market fell by historic levels
over the course of several days the
post-mortem analysis found that a
formula baked into the algorithms that
drive stock trades and sales tells these
systems to sell when workers wages go up
assuming that this is bad for the
businesses that employ them so this
collapse was driven in part by something
that I think we'd all assumed to be a
good thing more money in workers pockets
that may be logical from a profit
maximization perspective but it makes
you wonder what ethics and
intentionality was behind this design it
certainly isn't a formula that is good
for the vast majority of people in this
country yet it was there and humans put
it there the technology itself didn't
make the decision we did and the scan
technology magnify inequality and does
everyday across society now you may
interpret this as my questioning the
fundamentals of unbridled capitalism and
you'd be correct but this happens over
and over this process of designing
technology and algorithms to maximize
one goal in ways that can have
world-changing unforeseen consequences
and not in some theoretical future
right now today think about social media
in the last election algorithms that
optimize for clicks and engagement
fueled filter bubbles and drove the
spread of toxic fake news in ways
profitable immensely profitable for the
platforms but staggeringly destructive
as it turned out for American democracy
and unity as a result of simple
programming decisions built into an
agriturismo click here's the point on an
increasingly overcrowded warming hyper
connected planet we are running out of
time and space for profit motive
stripped of humanity in the design of
our technology we simply cannot afford
indifference to social consequences
because the costs are too sudden and too
high and so potentially catastrophic to
people communities countries and yes
even to business itself was the longtime
technology guru Tim O'Reilly told a
group of US foundations meeting in Miami
earlier this month we gathered to talk
about the future of journalism and the
future of news which is dire by the way
as Tim O'Reilly told us we are living
inside an algorithmic society that is
optimizing the wrong things so how do we
start optimizing for the right things
the technologies were creating must not
only have ethics baked into their design
but the technologists who are creating
them need to have a foundation in ethics
baked into them too and this is a
critical role that CMU and Metro 21 can
help to Pitt play so that brings me
finally to my third point almost done
and that's this is the challenge for CMU
I would ask you to double down on your
commitment to serve the but the public
good and to instill in your faculty
staff and students a deep sense of
responsibility commensurate to the
weightiness of the work happening on
this campus and its potential impacts on
our world you were at the epicenter of
the creation and application of these
technologies which is a point of pride
but how about we make sure we're also at
the epicenter of making them work for
the many not just for the few
to the corporate partners in this room I
would ask you to internalize how
important this work is for your own
long-term success Metro 21 certainly
needs your support your resources and
your participation the work here at
Carnegie Mellon does as well but you
also need the sort of comprehensive
approach that metro 21 represents an
increasingly unstable inequitable
anti-democratic Society is ultimately a
formula for collapse not profitability
this institute isn't a charity from a
business standpoint it's an investment
in your own future to all of us here I
would just say this we have right now
today all the resources the brainpower
and the technology to build a world that
works for everyone
we no longer have to relegate ourselves
to a Malthusian frame of scarcity and
competition for resources but what is
often missing is the intentionality to
train ourselves to think in the frame of
abundance and common well-being as we do
our work how is what we're building how
is what you're building how is what
you're supporting going to make life
better for a single mom in Homewood how
is what we're designing going to create
a better future for an out-of-work coal
miner in Green County how is what we're
proposing going to change the little the
life trajectory of a little girl growing
up here in public housing how is it
going to make our cities more functional
our communities more equitable and our
society more democratic as those
stewarding the next generation of
leaders in government technology and
business everyone in this room has a
sacred responsibility to ask these
questions of ourselves a responsibility
that I feel slipping away all too often
in our current morass of deep and
pervasive inequality and failing
institutions the bottom line is that we
have everything we need to build the
world we want we just have to decide
that we're going to do it I don't pose
this challenge to you lightly and I pose
it to myself as much as to you I don't
want to suggest that you're not already
thinking about these issues but I do
want you to push I do want to push you
to put it at the forefront of everything
that you're doing to make it
foundational not ancillary we're living
through unstable and challenging
times in the rapid deployment of
momentarily profitable but
longitudinally ill-conceived new
technologies could lead to further
destabilization and fear we see it in
our elections we see it in our economy
and we feel it in our national psyche
people have a deep sense that as these
technologies are becoming integrated
into our lives they're going they're
going to be winners and losers and a lot
of them genuinely believe that they will
be the losers so let's prove them wrong
let's use this platform you've built to
help restore trust in science in
expertise in policy and in governance
let's show the world that we can build
technology in the systems to apply it
that will make all of our lives better
regardless of the color of our skin the
place we live or how much money we have
in our bank accounts I pose this
challenge to you because I know you can
pull it off and as long as you do the
Heinz endowment will continue to be a
strong partner as you do thank you
you